are dudes getting bbl's i just saw uh
banmo uh bandman kevo got his body done
uh-huh dudes get well gay boys get bbl's
now dudes is so gay you're telling me
gay guys get the fake ass yeah you've
seen this i got one you got a bbl
your cheeks are
is it a fat reassignment what is going
on back there they just take it they
just take it from your stomach in your
waist and just put it in the back put it
in your ass and hips so you got the bbo
popping
where'd you go to get it down ski miami
was it painful nah
wow it's not
it's really not like you just wake up
you kind of swore a little bit and then
like you can't sit on your butt for like
uh four to six weeks i broke my tailbone
when i was in uh elementary school and i
had to sit on a donut uh-huh yeah that's
the thing they like a little you get
like a little donut or they get like a
little um
a little um thing that's like you could
sit but your butt doesn't sit on the
seat whenever you're sitting down well
yeah i saw you uh twerking on stage uh
unapologetically as you should uh at
rolling laps
and i was like
[ __ ] man dude's got cheeks paws you know
i mean dude's got some cheek stuff
so so at least we know now that you
wouldn't got them things situated uh-huh
enough for sure but most men like
surgery is so
normal now of course [ __ ] is going to
get abs and they
for sure i just um saw
you know we do a radio show every day so
obviously you know the hollywood unlocks
and shade rooms
there's this there's like a dick surgery
now where you can like get your dick
extended for real yeah i can't even
imagine how crazy it was i remember they
had the dick pump
oh yeah that's from like the 90s for
real my uncle had one i tried one three
yeah i had one how does it work
when i was like 19 when me and my baby
mama went to the porn store for the
first time i was like let me try this
thing let me tell you does it really
work i mean for a second oh [ __ ] that's
crazy
it's it's like it just sucks your dick
pause
[Laughter]
you like pump it and then like your dick
gets bigger in this tube and then like
you take it off it's not comfortable
but i only did it once i was a kid yeah
but yeah definitely not i wouldn't
suggest that i wouldn't suggest getting
this done
getting the surgery [ __ ] that now how
about you just you got what you got yes
work with what you got work with you
with what you got for sure it's so size
matter
not to me not to you there it is i don't
know you know your perspective some
ladies would say
it doesn't matter yeah it's about the
motion of the ocean young miami will say
it matters she would say it matters
she's
dating diddy-ish
yeah yeah
ish it's no it's really she she really
does she does date him um
she's got a great show huh i love her
new show yes i heard no kareesha please
it's so good yeah they confirmed that
you know on the show that that day well
i saw that and then i just started
twerking on cueva and rolling loud so we
entertainers we rappers for sure and we
outside
so just cuz you dating somebody like you
know what i'm saying they not married
they already said i'm dating this person
i'm dating this person but [ __ ] we
outside